this isn't a zombie show and I know
there's a zombie on screen but the last
of us is really a show about humans
even so it'll probably make the zombie
genre explode all over again and give
new life to the corpse that is zombie TV
over the past several years we've been
inundated with zombie TV shows and
movies that all look and feel kind of
the same and now we have this so you
might be wondering how exactly is The
Last of Us not a zombie show and to
answer that we'll have to discuss a few
things about the series character
Humanity World building and
oversaturation also we're going to talk
about how the series will revive the
zombie genre as a whole and give us a
new take on where the genre should be
headed first things first though we have
to talk about the show's character for
those unfamiliar with the PlayStation
game the series is based on the Last of
Us follows the story of Joel and Ellie
as they navigate a post-apocalyptic
World filled with deadly infected
creatures but this isn't just another
zombie story The Infected in the last of
us are not reanimated corpses but rather
humans who have been infected with the
fungus that's taken over their bodies
and turned them into monstrous creatures
this this small change to the
traditional zombie formula adds an
interesting twist and helps set the last
of us apart from other stories in the
genre but it's not just the infected
that sets The Last of Us Apart what
really makes this a standout story is
its emotional depth and complex
characters Joel and Ellie's relationship
is the heart of the story and their
character development is what truly
drives the narrative forward Joel is a
grizzled Survivor who's been through
hell and back and is struggling to come
to terms with the loss of his loved ones
Ellie on the other hand is a young girl
who's never known a world without the
infected and is trying to find her place
in this new dangerous World watching
these two characters grow and change as
they journey together is what makes the
last of us such a special and memorable
experience it's this emotional core
that'll make the HBO adaptation stand
out in the crowded World of Zombie media
the show has the potential to bring a
fresh perspective to the genre and
appeal to large audiences Beyond just
fans of the game too often zombie
stories are all about the action in the
gore and while those elements can
certainly be enjoyable they can also get
old pretty quickly The Last of Us on the
other hand is just as much about the
characters and their relationships as it
is about the infected and the action
this focus on character development and
emotion will bring a much needed breadth
of fresh air to the zombie genre The
Last of Us also tackle some pretty heavy
themes such as loss trauma and the cost
of survival in a way that few zombie
stories have before the game deals with
these themes in a mature and nuanced way
and the show has the potential to
continue this trend and delve even
deeper into these themes in a world
filled with Undead creatures in constant
danger it's only natural that characters
would be affected by trauma and loss the
show has the opportunity to explore
these themes in a way that feels
authentic and meaningful rather than
just using them as shallow plot points
but this brings up an important theme
that's Central to the argument that The
Last of Us isn't a zombie story and it's
that Humanity not zombies is the real
problem if you're familiar with the game
then you know that this is a theme that
runs throughout the story The Infected
are certainly a threat but it's the
other humans that the characters
encounter who are often the most
dangerous from Ruthless Bandits and
scavengers to well-meaning survivors who
will do whatever it takes to protect
their own the characters of the last of
us are constantly faced with the fact
that humans are just as dangerous as the
infected this theme is particularly
relevant in today's world where it
sometimes feels like humanity is Its Own
Worst Enemy from political strife and
social division to environmental
destruction it's easy to feel like the
real monsters are the humans around us
and The Last of Us touches on all of
these issues in a way that feels
relevant and timely in a world where
they infected are a constant threat it's
easy to see them as the enemy but the
last of us reminds us that it's often
Humanity that's the real danger it's
this theme that makes the last of us
such a relevant and thought-provoking
story in addition to its Incredible
World building the intricate and
well-developed environments in the game
are top-notch and the show has the
opportunity to expand on them even
further the showrunners Craig Mason and
Neil druckman have the freedom to
explore new story lines and expand on
the lore of the world beyond anything
we've seen before first off the cast is
absolutely incredible Joel is is being
played by Pedro Pascal who you may know
from his roles in Game of Thrones in the
Mandalorian and Ellie is being played by
Bella Ramsey who absolutely stole the
show as lyanna morma on Game of Thrones
these two actors have incredible
chemistry and it's clear that they're
going to bring Joel and Ellie to life in
a way that fans of the game will love
recently Pascal revealed that he and
Ramsay clicked instantly on set saying
it helped a lot to have Bella to
navigate the world of the last of us we
were stepping into this experience at
the same time and there was an immediate
Bond we've also gotten to see the
incredible attention to detail that the
show's production team is bringing to
the adaptation from the sets and costume
to the makeup and special effects
everything looks absolutely spot-on it's
clear that the team behind the show is
doing everything they can to make sure
that the adaptation stays true to the
spirit of the game and of course we
can't forget about the infected these
monstrous creatures are a key part of
the last of us and it looks like the
show's team is pulling out all the stops
to bring them to life in a way that's
both terrifying and realistic based on
what we've seen so far the infected are
going to be a highlight of the show and
will definitely give viewers some jump
scares lastly though let's talk about
the zombie genres over saturation it's
no secret that the zombie genre has been
over saturated in recent years with
countless movies TV shows and video
games featuring Undead creatures
shuffling about and feasting on human
flesh it's easy to feel like you've seen
it all before and it can be hard for new
entries in the genre to stand out but
that's where the Last of Us comes in
this series has the potential to
completely revive the zombie genre but
how exactly will it do this it's simple
by bringing something new to the table
the emotional depth and complex
characters of The Last of Us will set it
apart from other zombie stories and
bring a fresh perspective to a genre
that's felt washed out since the fifth
season of The Walking Dead The Last of
Us have the opportunity to appeal to
audiences Beyond just fans of the game
and bring in new viewers who may have
grown tired of the typical zombie story
Additionally the show's focus on
character development and World building
will help it stand out in a crowded
field too often zombie stories rely on
on cheap scares and Gore to carry the
narrative but the last of us has the
potential to go beyond that and explore
deeper themes and story lines it also
points the way for where zombie stories
should focus in the future not on the
undead creatures or blood and gore but
on the human conflicts and personal
sticks that arise because of a zombie
outbreak if there's one takeaway the
zombie genre should gain from studying
The Last of Us it's that they should
take a more grounded approach just like
the hardest difficulty in The Last of Us
game it's impossible to predict exactly
how the show will turn out but based on
the strength of the source material
there's no doubt that the last of us has
the potential to be a standout in the
zombie genre it has the opportunity to
bring something new and fresh to the
table and Revitalize a genre that's been
feeling a bit stale so don't be fooled
by the zombie aspect of the show The
Last of Us is so much more than that
it's a story about love loss and the
things we do for the people we care
about so it's not a zombie show it's a
story about the human condition and has
the potential to move and Inspire
audiences in a way that few others shows
can and I can't wait to see what it has
in store for us